[Music]
[Applause]
oh my god we need to here
today's news is nova max ivan
new tonight city it's not so bad here
how was feeling today because i feel
amazing
the food the tie on seventh and hayward
the pierogies down by the docks
a home of pride and as always
your business is my business
and this is your world news update
all my money
[Music]
endless possibilities and endless lies
[Music]
we are [ __ ] america and i don't know
how we're going to fix it
the homeless population in night city
has risen by 300
crime in night city is now double the
rate than in the new united states
[Music]
you want to be some kind of hero
that's a fight this city won't let you
win
on your own you're [ __ ]
well on that note that's it for today's
info flash sleep tight night city
the grass ain't greener anywhere else
night city what does it mean to you how
well do you know its history
who was richard knight how many stations
are in the end cart system
which city district boasts the best
burrito in town
the answers to these questions and more
can be found at the address at the
bottom of your screen
check it out and fall in love with night
city all over again
[Music]
you